wir schauen nach Moskau an diesem ganz
besonderen Tag denn heute feiert
Russland den Sieg über Nazi Deutschland
und Vladimir Putin hat das genutzt als
Tag als gigantisches propaganda-fest vor
wenigen Minuten ist diese große
Militärparade zu Ende gegangen
Kriegspropaganda XXL aber man muss sagen
für Putins Verhältnisse war das eher XXS
eine überraschende kleinlauträder hat er
dort gehalten ja und darüber wollen wir
sprechen zugeschaltet ist Paul
ronsheimer gemeinsam mit Wladimir
Klitschko also eher eine XXS Parade eine
kleinlautrede wie viel Hoffnung macht
das in der Ukraine für den weiteren
Verlauf des Krieges
ja darüber wollen wir sprechen mit
Wladimir Klitschko und Vitali Klitschko
Wladimir wir haben die Parade erlebt
aber vor allem haben wir eine Rede von
Putin erlebt wo er keine general mobil
machen angekündigt hat er hat auch nicht
mehr davon gesprochen dass er das ganze
Land einnehmen Wolle und er hat sich
sehr auf den Don Bass fokussiert
bedeutet das dass seine ursprünglichen
Kriegsziele nicht mehr erreichbar sind
ich glaube schon dass
diese Propaganda die schon seit
Jahrzehnten in Russland gelaufen ist
und auch der sinnlose Angriff der
Ukraine zeigt einfach dass
das anlügen eigentlich sich selbst und
auch für die Welt stimmt nicht und bei
diesen Aussagen so wie heute für
Russland in Moskau mit Putin gezeigt
einfach dass letztendlich die Wahrheit
kommt ins ans Licht und dank der
Wahrheit wird auch bald kommen
man kann nicht mit einem Krieg mit einer
vollkommen Mord sich rechtfertigen
unerheblichen Geschichten erzählen weil
wie gesagt es stimmt nicht den Realität
was gerade in der Ukraine passiert das
sinnlose Mördern für die vergewaltigen
und es ist wirklich ein Generation des
ukrainischen Volkes wird auch ein Ende
haben ein Ende der auch heißt mit
Verteidigung unsere Grenzen Vitali wie
hast du das wahrgenommen was Vladimir
Putin dort gesagt hat hättest Du damit
gerechnet dass er in diesem Krieg weiter
eskaliert oder ist das nicht
überraschend für dich das war eine große
Frage wird weit eskalieren die Krieg und
seine Rede war
mittlerweile nicht so aggressiv wie er
erwartet hat weil er keine Musik
Mobilisierung war dass es keine das bis
heute über eine spezielle sogenannte
spezielle Operation und wir haben
keine Angst wir haben vermutet wer wird
eine Krieg analysiert gegen Ukraine ist
nicht passiert das bedeutet das bedeutet
diese in seiner Rede er hat erzählt für
alle sind schuldig aus und die russische
Regierung
wie man kann so sagen zurück zurückzieht
ein bisschen aber das ist seine Zeichen
alles was machst du keine das ist für
dating seine Territorium alles was wir
machen die
Freunde durch eine die ganze
demokratische Welt die unterstützt durch
eine und sagt sie Krieg muss beendet
werden drussen müssen weg von noch eine
das hat eine Wirkung
wir sehen dass es wir haben
es wird wir erinnern uns an die ersten
Kriegstage mit Euch beiden hier in Kiew
wo große Nervosität war wo die
russischen Truppen die Stadt versucht
haben einzukesseln jetzt versucht man
nachdem man in Kiew nicht erfolgreich
war im Osten erfolgreich zu sein was ist
aus deiner Sicht dort für Russland
militärisch noch möglich wenn man sich
anschaut dass die Armee schon ziemlich
dezimiert ist die russische
Armee ist de malerisiert und das ist
sehr viel ständig seit längerer Zeit zu
kämpfen und in eine fremdes Land wo die
Bevölkerung unterstützt vor und hasst
Adresse
das ist ziemlich schwer dass es kostet
bestimmt
dann nach Russland sehr große
finanzielle Belastung für russische
Wirtschaft und deswegen die Putin
versucht jetzt eine Ausrede zu zu finden
wenn er den Krieg beenden oder will er
weiter installieren aus deiner Sicht
meine Macht nach wenn Putin wird kam
zurück alles drehen bis zum 24
Februar dann wird dann er hat nicht
erwartet die ganze Welt unreine steht
und wird auch eine und Frieden
verteidigen heute versucht er eine gute
Miene bei schlechten Spiel haben
Vladimir aus deiner Sicht wie wird
dieser Krieg jetzt in den nächsten
Wochen Monaten weitergehen wenn man sich
anschaut das Wladimir Putin auch nicht
mehr davon spricht hier eure Hauptstadt
einnehmen zu wollen sondern sich auf den
don-bass fokussiert wenn ich dort mit
Soldaten gesprochen habe dann haben wir
viele Soldaten dort gesagt im Don was
sie wollen selbst in die Offensive also
die russischen Truppen komplett aus dem
Land zu drängen ist das das Ziel dass
keine russischen Truppen mehr im Don was
insgesamt sind oder wird es eine
Verhandlungslösung geben
es ist einfach nur falsch das russische
drucken überhaupt auf dem ukrainischen
Boden sind die sollten hier nicht sein
es ist nicht deren Land ist nicht deren
Rechnung anzugreifen vor allem auch das
Volker Mode ist ein Thema tausende von
Zivilisten sind
erneutes wurden
bis 1000 Kinder sind ermordet worden das
muss gestoppt werden
es gibt nur eine Lösung im Krieg die
russische
militärkräften sollten
wieder nach Hause gehen und von
ukrainischen militärischen Kräften
entsprechend auch verteidigt bis den
letzten
Soldat bis letzten
ukrainischen Stadt befindet wird auf dem
grünen Boden
wie eskaliert das welche Waffen noch im
Einsatz gebracht werden können von
russischen Seite chemische Waffen jede
andere Art von Waffen man hat schon die
Rede gehabt von
primitiven Atombomben das ist alles
Ungewissenheit eine was wir wissen wie
Ukraine stehen zu unserem Recht zu
existieren Leben und kreieren ein
kreatives Leben und kein destruktives
Leben das was Russland das Destruktive
was Russland in unsere Heimatland die
Ukraine gebracht Vitali die Situation in
Kiew wir haben während der Parade von
Wladimir Putin wieder Luftalarm gehört
wie gefährlich ist die Lage noch wir
sehen das Botschafter zurückkommen die
us-botschafterin wieder hier ist wir
gehen davon dass auch die deutsche
Botschaft wieder eröffnet wie gefährlich
ist die Lage in der Hauptstadt man spürt
jetzt immer mehr nicht die große
Spannung wie haben wir vor einer oder
vor zwei Monate gehabt hin in Kiefer ist
er als relativ ruhig aber trotzdem wir
können eine Sicherheitsgarantie geben
für jeden weil jede Sekunde jede Minute
kann eine Rakete landen in unsere Stadt
und schon mal passiert vor
noch vor einer Woche ist schon wieder
Rakete Angehörigen Angriff gehabt und
wieder Zivilisten gestorben
hoffen wir hoffen wir wird ruhiger aber
trotzdem wir müssen nicht vergessen dass
es Park 100 km von Osten von Kiew
jetzt läuft eine richtige Schlacht und
jeden Tag Menschen sterben deswegen man
kann nicht
sprechen ob er ruhiger Zeit man muss
selbstverständlich ist bisschen ruhiger
als bevor aber trotzdem die Spannung
bleibt noch in man spielt das in Luft du
und Wladimir ihr standet auch auf der
Todesliste oder steht auf der
sogenannten Todesliste von Wladimir
Putin weil er eben so eine prominente
Rolle hier gespielt habt oder immer noch
spielt wie viel Angst müsst ihr noch um
euer Leben haben gibt es Provokateure
noch in der Stadt die ist auch auf euch
abgesehen haben wir denken nicht darüber
wissen was
jeder von nur 40 Millionen Ukraine war
lebten das Land steht in eine Todesliste
jede will er Toten wir sehen Beispiele
mariupel Harke
Europe wie viel Zivilisten schon
gestorben ohne sogenannte Todesliste und
deswegen wenn man denkt darüber dass es
gibt keinen Sinn wir kämpfen um unseres
Land und wie verteidigen uns wie greifen
an keine wir sind deine friedliche Volk
und wir wissen keinen Krieg und die
Russen muss das Verstehen und die letzte
russische Soldaten muss raus von unseres
Land wir waren noch einmal kurz über die
Debatte in Deutschland sprechen Wladimir
und Vitali wir haben am Wochenende
erlebt das ist bei
Gedenkveranstaltungen nicht erlaubt war
die ukrainische Flagge dabei zu haben an
Gedenkorten das hatte das Land Berlin
verfügt die Polizei verfügt und wir
haben gesehen wie dann eine große
ukrainische Flagge tatsächlich von der
Polizei dort eingerollt wurde was macht
das mit euch ihr habt deutsch hat
sozusagen neben dem ukrainischen wenn
ihr diese Bilder da in Berlin seht kein
Verständnis dafür weil vor vier Wochen
durften dann russische
Autos in großen Mengen mit russischen
Flaggen durch die Städte ziehen und
durchziehen und es war okay und die
ukrainische Fahne während diesen Kriegs
wenn
eine Zerstörung von Infrastruktur und
Töten von Zivilisten man die ukrainische
Fahne zusammengefoldet hat das es gibt
kein Verständnis
nicht auf politische und auf keinen Fall
auf persönlich Ebene Vitali was macht
das mit dir der Außenminister der
ukrainische Außenminister hat das stark
kritisiert also russische und
ukrainische Flaggen sind und waren am 8
und 9 mai verboten ukrainische Flaggen
wurden richtig ähm von der Polizei ähm
dann eingerollt was macht das mit dir
als jemand der in Deutschland viel
gewohnt ist ich spreche mit viele
Bürgermeister von ganze Welt ich spreche
mitreden repräsentativen von die ganze
viele Länder und heute ist jedes Land
jedes Stadt hat so viele ukrainische
Fahne das ist eine Zeichen Unity hier
die Zeichen nur durch Unterstützung
durch eine und deswegen schwierig zu
verstehen wieso ist doch keine sind
verboten weil an diesem bestimmten Tagen
ich verstehe wahrscheinlich gibt muss
keine Spannung sein und wahrscheinlich
die können aus reden machen war und die
Gründen wieso ist das aber denke ich mal
denke ich mal heute auch rheinische
Fahne
das ist eine simval für eine simval von
eine kampfju Frieden und für Frieden und
gegen die Krieg und deswegen für uns für
du keine schwierig das ist alles zu
verstehen aber was was wichtig zu hören
gewesen gestern die relativ lange Rede
von Olaf Scholz und seine Zustimmung an
der Seite der Ukraine zu stehen auch
auch mit Lieferung von schwerwaffen eine
Verteidigung in eine Front gegen diesen
sinnlosen Kriegen gegen diese Aggression
von Russland das war ganz wichtig zu
hören und ich hoffe auch dass weiterhin
mit Daten kommen wird und man darf auch
nicht vergessen
das Deutschland hat die Ukraine
unterstützt stark unterstützt und ich
hoffe dass wir gesagt die Unterstützung
wird weiter folgen
so lange diese Krieg herrscht und auch
für die Zeit nach dem Glück herzlichen
Dank Wladimir Klitschko herzlichen Dank
Vitali Klitschko ja nach Deutschland aus
und damit zurück ins Studio